hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors attention ornithorynque o
arn i&t horizon-1 cul oui c'est bon
attention attention si vous donnez un
premier mon attention c'est parti
il va falloir il faut que vous mais pas
les thierry 15-15 gérard à lorca cohen
oui j
non j ai race et non non non pas il
manque un mot il en canette fait danser
la semaine j y
non qu'elle jjg encore les journées
génie des jgr assez ouais j'ai bon là
elle est ici et on mélange bien savoir
en forme parce que là encore encore
mélangé les bulls est cool mais c'est
quoi 25 on continue c'est au unis ll es
quoi qu il en soit c'est énorme
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même militaire bienfaits [ __ ] qui
équivaut cyril hanouna
qu'allez-vous qui tourne en fait prendre